I told that you brought something
special with you today yeah and this is
uh this is a real treat can we can we do
this now yeah we can I figured this was
because it's Comic Con this would be the
place to do this but I have
tell them what this is but this is cool
you should hear what this is this is
fascinating so this is the well it's the
one right no it's the why no but there
are effects similarly this is this is
the real thing so I was given this ring
when we commenced principal photography
of all of the films I'm a ring bearer so
they gave it to me it's an incredible
thing to have this is absolutely
incredible and it's got the real Elvis
writing on it right yeah and it's got
all the the fine details what is I mean
a sword I think one of the swords from
Lord of the Rings just sold for over a
hundred thousand dollars is that true
this is what I heard yeah a hundred
thousand dollars what do you think this
would be worth I'm serious what do you
think what would the price be first I've
never really thought about the value of
these things and some I just found out
about this sword going front a thousand
dollars which is crazy I mean there are
I think maybe ten of these in existence
right it would have to be comparable
[Applause]
that was Gandhi with psoriasis lady
we'll take a break we'll be right back
North Elijah way